Narrator: WHEN YOU GAZE UP
AT THE NIGHT SKY,
YOU SEE STARS.
THESE GLITTERY BALLS...
[ LAUGHS ]
[ TAPE REWINDING ]
NOPE.
THESE ORBS OF SWIRLING GASES
ARE PRETTY COOL.
LIKE PEOPLE,
EVERY STAR IS UNIQUE.
SIZE, COLOR, TEMPERATURE,
WHICH IS MEASURED IN KELVIN,
ARE SUPER-HOT TEMPERATURES.
IF YOU'RE REALLY WARM
AND YOU'RE LIKE,
"I WONDER WHAT THE TEMPERATURE
IS IN KELVIN?"
YOU'VE GOT BIGGER PROBLEMS.
WHEN A YELLOW STAR, LIKE OUR
SUN, USES UP MOST OF ITS FUEL,
IT GROWS TO A MASSIVE SIZE
AND TURNS RED.
ASTRONOMERS CLEVERLY DUBBED THIS
GIANT RED STAR...
PHBT.
THIS RED GIANT IS A GREEDY
MOTHER[BLEEP]
IT WILL EAT NEARBY PLANETS
AND EXPLODE IN A HUGE FIREBALL.
IN SPACE, IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS...
[ SILENCE ]
WHAT'S LEFT IS A MUCH SMALLER
STAR BURNING WHITE,
CALLED A WHITE DWARF.
THERE ARE ALSO BROWN DWARVES
AND BLACK DWARVES.
THEY ALSO MATTER.
THE UNIVERSE DOESN'T
DISCRIMINATE.
LIKE MOST OF YOUR FRIENDS,
MANY STARS ARE IN PAIRS,
ALSO CALLED BINARY.
OUR SUN IS ALONE, ALSO CALLED...
AND FOR THE REALLY KINKY,
THERE ARE THREE-STAR
AND FOUR-STAR SYSTEMS.
Man: OH, YEAH.
Narrator: BINARY STARS
DON'T ALWAYS GET ALONG.
USUALLY ONE GETS BIGGER,
AND AS GRAVITY STEALS MATERIAL
FROM THE SMALLER STAR,
LIKE MY EX.
THESE ARE CALLED VAMPIRE STARS
BECAUSE ASTRONOMERS FINALLY
PULLED A SENSE OF HUMOR
OUT OF THEIR ASS.
THE VAMPIRE SUCKS THE LIFE OUT
OF THE VICTIM,
WHICH GETS SMALLER
AND DENSER
WHILE THE VAMPIRE GROWS SO BIG
THAT IT FEEDS THE MATERIAL
RIGHT BACK TO THE VICTIM STAR,
NOT UNLIKE THIS BIRD
REGURGITATING ITS LUNCH
INTO ITS BABY'S MOUTH.
IN SUMMARY, STARS ARE BORN,
THEY LIVE FOR BILLIONS OF YEARS,
AND THEN THEY DIE.
OUR SUN HAS BURNED
FOR 4 BILLION YEARS.
BUT DON'T WORRY.
IT WON'T DIE UNTIL THURSDAY.
JUST KIDDING.
NEXT THURSDAY.